[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
[Music]
all right and we are live lord cognito
here on love podcast lords of gaming.net
and who is this foreign gentleman in the
realm today at play nyc
uh my name is keiko i'm the creative
director of rushdown revolt
all right yeah let's tell reebok now you
gotta tell us about rushdown revo
this game looks pretty cool i love the
art style for those who don't know
anything about the game
what is this game about so basically our
idea was to take the the formula kind of
that that everybody knows about super
smash brothers and make it into
something that's
much more intense and hardcore actually
more intense and hardcore you have to
explain to us how this is possible yeah
it's it's kind of uh it's kind of scary
with fighting games a lot of people say
you know fighting games need to be made
more casual
and like that's led to a lot of pushback
in the fighting game community and we
thought
let's see if we can make a game like
smash
that was designed to for kids right a
party game
and try to make it more competitive so
we added a lot of like
uh anime fighter tech uh like uh arcade
fighter tech
and so there's a lot of like things like
parries or like animation cancels
that uh that make the game pretty pretty
cool i gotta slow you down
now you're getting into my heart now now
you talk about parry's
animation cap this is like the fgc's
dream now
you're getting hardcore down yes that's
what i'm saying
it's got a lot of really cool tech in it
and uh yeah uh
it's been two years in the making too so
one of the things that's pretty crazy is
there's actually um a mechanic in the
game called rush which is like an
air uh an air dash right so you can air
dash after every attack
okay and every time you land an attack
you can air dash again
and the airdash is the animation cancel
so now i can attack you airdash attack
you airdash
basically like these infinites yeah um
and um the the entire game had to be
redesigned around that
concept because it's so kind of like
crazy
i guess yeah now i want to know from
from a narrative perspective yeah like
what's the
narrative the storyline the baseline
story of
rushdown uh the story of the game
honestly is kind of like the story of us
as a developer
uh where uh you know tell a little bit
about us and then how it fits into the
lore
basically you have um
uh we had a game uh that was um
much more directly inspired by smash
brothers
and there wasn't really a lot of reason
to play it and it was just kind of like
this thing that existed
and over the last two years we said
let's just totally change it totally
like
overhaul everything and let's see how
crazy things can get
and in the game there's this mechanic
called spark
which is think of it like the force in
star wars
right but imagine if like one day in
star wars they were like you know what
anybody can learn how to use the force
okay okay how crazy that would be
yes right like all of the problems that
would cause for like you know the dark
side the light side
everybody can do this [ __ ] now you're
not you're not that powerful anymore
everybody everybody can trade it so so
basically the spark has been unleashed
on the world now
and the people who are in power are like
kind of freaking out but some of them
are like very excited about it because
you know
they weren't the biggest honcho but
they're going to mobilize an army
you know to to overthrow people so
there's a big power grab in the game
all right so we got we got to fight for
power here which i like now as far as
amount of characters stages what can you
tell us about that
so that's something that's always
changing uh i think for us we have nine
characters right now
and they are extremely different
this is not your typical nine character
roster
who are these two right here uh well
there's gonna be constantly changing but
uh we've got you know sword fighter
we've got this guy with a big gwanda
with a massive spear we've got a
grappler
we've got uh several different styles of
projectile zoner characters
we have some setup characters we have a
character that has like micro mechanics
like rts kind of micro uh where you have
two different people you're controlling
at once
that's very intense a lot of like very
very different character designs in this
game
um and in terms of like content you know
we are
i think we have like 18 stages or
something like that
and uh constantly putting out new ones
nice yeah i think the big thing actually
is
our focus of building this core combat
what can we do with that next do we want
to make like speed running challenges do
we want to make like puzzle
kind of mini games do we want to make
like team based combat
so uh you know expect to see a lot more
beyond just kind of 1v1 fighting from us
this is yeah first of all it's pretty
exciting and what i like is
how ambitious you guys are yeah like
there's a lot going on with the
complexity
and just the way you guys think and i
was also incorporating yourselves as a
studio
into the lore of the game is pretty cool
so as far as platforms
where are we right now where can we
expect it as far as
what it's called i'm seeing xbox
controllers but i i i need to know if we
get a confirmation on that
so right now we are on steam uh and
we're gonna be
uh pc only for probably the next few
months but we're coming to mac and linux
soon
and by next year we hope to be on every
console nice now you said
linux so i have to ask the question if
you're allowed
there's this thing called the steam deck
very familiar yes
i'm familiar too yeah so is it possible
you know that you guys will be working
without as far as
trying to get this on the device or is
that something we can look forward to
because
it seems like i think that's something
you could definitely look forward to
from us
yeah no doubt but you heard it here
first
rush down revolt looks pretty cool i
love the art style animations look cool
backgrounds look amazing ambitious title
you heard it here first and again where
can people try to support the game where
can they go
i would recommend everybody join the
discord uh discord dot gg
slash rushdown revo uh we view
our community and our discord as
something that's just as important to
invest in as the game
uh we actually like don't do any
advertising like yes we have the booth
here yeah but we have like
you know twice the cost of the booth in
swag that we're just giving away to
people
we're just giving this away to people
because we have like uh
you know five thousand dollar prize pool
at the end of the month um
you know we're about taking whatever we
would be putting into marketing and just
giving it to the players
awesome and we've also got rushdown uh
our revolt university
which is a real tell me about that it's
a real partnership program where
no matter how new you are as a player or
as a streamer or anything
no minimum you know like uh viewership
no cost to enter so i don't have to have
ten thousand subs to get there
we literally we literally will just hook
you up and we'll try to help you get to
the next level oh that's awesome
and so like everything about what we're
doing is trying to
help you you know reach your potential
it's like unleash your spark is what we
see in our marketing so
there you go yo rush down revolt i'm
liking the energy
i'm liking the movement really cool we
got to track this one this low looks
fire
i cannot wait and again even from the
steam deck y'all so look there's no
excuse all the platform
and hopefully console because yeah we
got like i said the xbox community would
love to play it
i know the switch community would love
to play especially with the smash
influence yeah
you know so this is something to look
out for absolutely thank you so much
guys this has been awesome you already
know all right little podcast
lordcognito here
lawyergaming.net rush down revoke get
your hands on it man it's a good story
behind it
[Music]
you